for najin and her daughter Fatu it's
been a day like any other but not for
the conservationists who look after them
they're the last remaining Northern
white rhinos in the world looked after
with extreme care under 24hour armed
guard at the old pajetta
Conservancy but far from the foothills
of Mount Kenya scientists have just
announced a major breakthrough that
could change everything for their
species really important moment
and um I'm really emotionally um shaked
up an international team of researchers
has created the first successful
pregnancy in the closely related
southern white rhino using invitro
fertilization achieved together uh
something which was not believed to be
possible I think the
bio rescu Consortium worked so hard and
so effective together with all our
partners uh that uh we really made the
impossible
possible with this Milestone scientists
will attempt to replicate the feat later
this year but with an embryo from a
northern White Rhino implanted in a
surrogate if the 16-month pregnancy is
successful it would be the first of its
kind since
2000 hosting the last two known to exist
Northern White rhinos is a huge
responsibility and it reminds us every
morning that if nothing is
done then we are facing extinction that
we do whatever it takes whatever humanly
possible to make sure that these animals
do not uh disappear from the face of the
Earth the reproduction program is the
northern white Rhino's last chance of
survival but the team said says it has
great potential beyond that and can be
used to save other highly endangered
species around the world Alexandra buers
Al
jazer make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jazer